à partir du moment où j'ai dit aux airs de taureau que
leurs parents ont péri dans un terrible
incendie, ils ont eu des aventures et toutes
sortes de lieux exotiques, je viens de les
déposer à l'internat, je
sais tout sur vous, vous avez été envoyé au
gardien après Guardian  et l'adversité
a toujours suivi J'ai peur que
vous deviez vivre dans une petite cabane en fer blanc
craps nos chakras crabes ses parents faisaient
partie de quelque chose pourrait être la raison pour laquelle
toutes ces choses terribles continuent de se produire Le
comte Olaf nous cherche toujours
fait ça  sembler être un cauchemar parce
que c'est l'effet que je recherchais
qui est cet homme qui s'est
déguisé était au milieu d'un stratagème
pour voler notre fortune
que dit l'homme ce qui s'est déguisé
quatre fois de suite nous avons perdu nos parents
dans le feu  nous avons aussi perdu nos parents
nous avons vu beaucoup de choses que nous ne pouvons pas
expliquer
est-ce que nous
avons des yeux ev  partout et nous
regardons toujours  la façon dont l'ambassadeur de la
camaraderie dans cet hôpital est vraiment
inspirant
j'ai besoin de me garder je vous souhaite bonne chance
je pense que vous en aurez besoin cet
épisode de la vie des Baudelaires est
sur le point de devenir bien pire
comment le travail était ensoleillé plus vite vous tapez  comme un enfant d'
un an
Oh